welcome to the livestream thanks for
joining me going to give it a minute or
two for people to get connected bunch of
people with a variety of questions that
they were submitting via Twitter and
hopefully we will be able to get to
those a little bit later I'm going to be
talking about a lot of different things
on the stream I mean generally the
question is how long can the current
political status quo go on because
things have gotten pretty damn nuts but
that's going to include conversations
about Plan C already being dead with
health care it's going to talk it's
gonna involve talking about Trump Russia
it's going to involve talking about
Democrats and I also I'm going to
announce and preview something that
we're gonna be doing on the program next
week which I think some of you will like
and some of you will probably hate
because I don't know of the 380,000
subscribers that we have you can always
count on a few thousand hating some
aspect of what I'm doing if this is your
first live stream this is a live stream
meaning we're live unless you're
watching a replay and as a result
because we're live I can answer
questions and comments from you as you
submit them and the best way to do that
is through the super chat function which
is the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window for the YouTube live stream
the chat often moves very very quickly
but super chat will get to me and if you
have questions or comments by all means
submit them there and I will get to them
number three new members and patrons
will get live thank-yous and shout out
during the program you can learn about
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership you can learn about patreon
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and lastly please don't troll we
actually had someone get banned today
before the chat before the live stream
even started which is fascinating that
that's some kind of record I guess
somebody getting blocked before we even
start usually you know it's like 10
seconds in that the first person gets
blocked but somebody already blocked
before we even started subtle trolling
will not get you banned because we
probably won't notice it and before we
jump into the politics might
challenge for this livestream to see if
we can get to 1,800 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'm
trying to get to 2,000 is the broader
goal and when we get to 2,000 I will do
an entire broadcast program from David
Pakman show Studios in Boston
Massachusetts with my hair like this
which is you know a little bit of a
disturbing sight but I will do it if and
when we get to 2,000 patrons but as a
intermediate step I would love your help
in getting to 1,800 patrons and the
thing about patreon is we're just trying
to get to a number of patrons that means
that if you can donate a dollar or two
or ten or a hundred it all counts the
same because we have a patron target and
if we get just 33 patrons during the
stream we will get to 1,800 and
everybody every single person who makes
a pledge during the stream will get a
live shout out and thank you so please
check that out more information
forthcoming about all of that stuff so
the big question we're talking about
today is how long can this insanity
continue the insanity that we are seeing
from the Trump administration and sort
of the political status quo
it is promise after broken promise from
the Trump administration and Republicans
at the top of that list obviously is
what's going on with health care we saw
yesterday we learned that the second
iteration of the Senate version of the
American Health Care Act has failed okay
it was not going to get enough support
to pass the Senate so it was dead and
then we heard from Donald Trump and from
Mitch McConnell and increasingly from
Republicans okay listen if we can't get
a consensus on a replacement let's just
repeal the Affordable Care Act we will
do a straight repeal vote and see if we
can get that done and then we will worry
about a replacement later that is what
we are calling Plan C plan C is already
dead it's done I mean it lasted a couple
of hours and already today we have
learned that three senators Susan
Collins
and Shelley capito and Lisa Murkowski
all said yeah we're not going to do it
we're not voting for it so it's
effectively dead they've got 52 senators
they need 52 vote for whatever they want
to do and they are already down to only
49 so that is already dead now I
proposed on the program today that the
failure to repeal the Affordable Care
Act with or without a replacement could
end up being a victory in disguise for
Republicans because yes it is a broken
campaign promise but if Republicans were
to successfully repeal and replace the
Affordable Care Act at least with what
they've proposed so far you would see
20-something million people end up
without care and that would have I I
hope I would believe political
repercussions for Republicans not doing
anything will have the failure of the
failed campaign promise attached to it
but it will probably do less damage than
kicking all those people off of health
insurance because in the end many
ideologically committed trumpets you're
just gonna blame Democrats anyway I know
that you've got a Republican controlling
the White House Republicans controlling
the Senate and Republicans controlling
the House of Representatives but there
are ideologically committed trumpets
suffering from significant cognitive
dissonance who will find some way to
blame Obama or Hillary or Seth rich is a
popular one now or comet ping-pong
pizzeria they'll find someone to blame
and Trump will avoid the repercussions
where that may be tougher if 22 million
people end up losing their health
coverage so that's something to think
about and I my primary concern is for
people not to lose health insurance and
so that's the main reason to be happy
that Obamacare repeal is dead for now
that Affordable Care American Health
Care Act rather is dead for now those
are good things because somewhere
between 22 and 32 million people
depending on which iteration we're
talking about will not end up without
health insurance
Obamacare is still part of the crony
for-profit employer connected capitalist
health care system we have which is an
absolute
total disaster doesn't change that but
this may also be a blessing for
Republicans in some way and that is
unfortunate because they've not earned
that they've never earned that it's only
through promises they couldn't keep and
a total lack of understanding of the
issue that this has taken place and as a
result it's nothing that I would applaud
Republicans for now at the same time
that the health care situation has
completely imploded the Russia story
continues to grow and at this point the
people that are in the stream or that
are watching this later or that are on
our channel who have been telling me
that there's no story for months and
this includes right-wingers and left
wingers how can anyone say that at this
point
how can anyone at this point believe
that there is nothing to see here
with Russia when we have confirmed in
writing the intent to collude for the
benefit of Donald Trump and to the
detriment of Hillary Clinton at this
point the only question well there's
actually sort of three questions
actually probably more like five but
some of the questions that remain are to
what extent did Trump in Russia collude
how knowledgeable was Donald Trump
personally was any of the collusion
criminal was any of the cover-up
criminal right so these are the new
questions the question of whether there
was collusion coordination that
questions done that is no longer a
question based on what we've learned
will we ever get answers to these
questions I don't know I don't know and
there are still ideologically committed
Republicans who sort of don't really
want answers to those questions they
want to talk about conspiracy theories
they want to talk about Hillary's emails
they want to talk about the DNC DNC a
completely valid topic that I have been
covering for a very long time but it is
not relevant to whether or not Donald
Trump was aware of the collusion with
Russia it's not relevant to whether
crimes were committed it's not relevant
to whether there was a sustained coverup
etc etc it said
and then on the back end of this is the
job situation the job situation which
has seen the Trump administration now
hold up as evidence of their great
economic programs the same Bureau of
Labor Statistics data that were bogus
under the Obama administration with no
serious plan to deal with the
destruction of manufacturing jobs due to
automation with no serious economic
policy to stop companies like Ford or
carrier or whoever from outsourcing
programs even the carrier bribe that
Donald Trump and Mike Pence touted as a
major economic accomplishment has
already imploded as carrier has
announced that there they are going to
be reducing jobs in the United States so
every aspect of this every aspect of
this going wrong and I don't know how
long it's going to go on and as some
people in the chatter saying it could go
on eight years and that is why if we
want it to only go on for another three
and a half years and not another eight
and a half I'm sorry a seven and a half
years then Democrats have to get it
together as far as policy goes and
you've got to pursue Trump Russia and
enable Robert Moeller and to do his job
and continue to support the great
investigative work of the New York Times
in the Washington Post which has been
absolutely an utterly spot-on
but that is not going to be enough to
justify people voting for you in 2018
and in 2020 you need to talk about
health care that needs to be a cohesive
policy there needs to be some some
coalition that is created so that you
can eliminate the infighting when it
comes to a number of foreign policy
related issues that are going on there's
a long list and I've been talking about
it for a while and it's got to be talked
about and
unless that happens Trump could
basically do whatever he wants and it is
unlikely that we are going to see some
major Democratic victory in 2018 now if
Democrats get it together they can take
the house in 2018 and possibly the
Senate I've looked at the analyses it's
possible I'm not making any kind of
prediction what I'm telling you is that
if the right steps are taken
it is possible and then you will have a
totally impotent Trump in the White
House right now it's scandal that has
been interrupting the legislative agenda
of the president combined with
Republicans not being able to get behind
proposals because they would actually be
really bad for voters but if you have a
Democratic takeover of the house and/or
Senate in 2018 Donald Trump is instantly
a lame duck instantly a lame duck and I
think that that is going to be something
that I will be talking about more and
more over the coming probably six months
I do want to announce to you that on
Tuesday July 25th we will have Dave
Rubin host of the Rubin report for the
entire hour on our broadcast show rather
than the normal seven stories and a
voicemail with a short interview next
Tuesday
the full hour we will have Dave Rubin
and we are going to dig in in detail to
a number of issues I've already received
60 or 70 suggestions for questions or
topics to broach with Dave Rubin many
people want to know if is Dave Rubin now
considering himself a right-winger many
people want to know what does Rick Dave
Rubin think that Donald Trump has done
wrong
particularly since some in my audience
believe Dave Rubin has not been critical
of Donald Trump I don't know the answer
to that I will review the evidence
between now and then so we will have
Dave Rubin on for the entire program on
Tuesday the best way for you to
communicate topics to me are probably be
an email so if you go to david
pakman.com go to the contact form and
send me your questions and comments that
is going to be on Tuesday and on that
day the bonus show which is our Members
Only program we do every day instead of
being extra stories we will have sort of
like the core political stories of the
day instead of being on the broadcast
show on Tuesday they
we'll be on the bonus show on Tuesday so
yet another reason to become a member
which is the number one way that we are
supported and I believe that it is going
to be a very very interesting interview
assuming that it happens and I have no
reason to think that it will not let's
get to some of the super chats by the
way I am asking for your help today in
getting to 1,800 patreon donors we are
at 1767 right now meaning that 33 more
donors gets us to 1800 the reason we are
raising this money is because
unfortunately our YouTube revenue has
effectively disappeared we've lost
eighty-five percent of our YouTube
revenue as a result of the YouTube
advertiser boycott some people are
calling it ad pocalypse you can call it
whatever you want as long as you
understand the urgency of the situation
I am asking for your help even just $1 a
month is going to help get us there to
1800 patrons by the end of the stream
every single person who makes a pledge
at patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will personally thank you live during
the stream okay so please keep that in
mind
get those pledges in and I will I will
thank everybody and we will start thank
you shortly as we've already had a few
people start signing up for memberships
so on that note let's get to the super
chat questions that we are seeing a rich
ro path accent a $2.00 super chat
related to dave rubin what's your
opinion on Dave Reubens reddit AMA I
have not seen it I will be reviewing it
in advance of our extensive detailed
interview scheduled for Tuesday by the
way every once in a while this happens
it's funny that this comment this thing
about whether I'm gay is happening again
in the chat and some people actually
said I've confirmed I'm gay multiple
times I don't know what my sexual
orientation has to do with anything
I am I'm heterosexual I have only dated
women in my life
thank you very much with peace and love
why it matters I don't know gr has sent
a five-dollar super chat Pakman a man
indeed not only once with the truth but
indeed twice with the truth or more
certainly the dzb of man indeed
si gr now with an unfettered month month
upon month track record of completely
incoherent super chats but we appreciate
his support no doubt about that
Darryl Dudley has sent the $5 super chat
what's the term you used in the past for
making up so much stuff that you don't
know what to believe okay
I think you might be confusing two
things Darryl I've talked about the the
debate technique called the Gish gallop
the Gish gallop is a debate technique
where you cram in a whole bunch of stuff
in a short period of time and then your
opponent basically is unable to refute
all of it and it can kind of come off
like you made some good points so you
know you might say something like well
my opponent is personally a terrible
person you should see what he does to
his wife and by the way he's lying about
health care and he also has never voted
for a tax decrease in his life and then
60 second rebuttal right and then the
your opponent couldn't possibly refute
everything so that's a debate technique
the other thing is I've talked about how
the book brave new world by Aldous
Huxley is sort of more in line with what
we're seeing right now in American
political society visa vie the Trump
administration then 1984 insofar as it's
not that there's sort of like a
limitation on media outlets or speech
but because of the blurring of news and
opinion journalism because of fake news
websites because of real news websites
being called fake news there's just a
generalized confusion about man what can
I believe anything could be true it's
just too confusing I'm not gonna worry
about it type of thing so I think that
there might be two different things
there Darryl that were confused gr has
sent a $2 super jet D
tell 30 memberships guy I love him love
gr okay
what gr is talking about is that a david
pakman show viewer named Marshall brats
has subsidized half of 30 memberships
okay so what Marshall has done is he we
a yearly membership is $60 on our
website this gets you the commercial
free all-access pass and the bonus show
and yada yada yada
Marshall brats came to us and said I'm
gonna send you nine hundred dollars okay
this is to be allocated as paying for
half of 30 people's memberships and what
we are allowing for is for 30 people to
now get
memberships at half price and because we
are doing these first-come first-served
I've got three left of these okay we
announced this yesterday we had eight
left as of earlier today we now have
three left if you want one of the
half-price memberships just send me an
e-mail okay go to david pakman.com click
on contact us and say hey I want one of
Marshalls memberships or the half-price
memberships or whatever and then I'll
get back to you with a coupon code
there's just three left okay so I would
I would do that sooner than later if
that's something you're interested in
Frank macwrite has sent a twenty dollar
super check interested in your opinion
of an ideal health care plan I still
feel like we have to deal with the greed
of the insurance companies they don't
provide care only the ticket price and
their concern is money not health I mean
we need to be looking at the most
successful health care plans among the
wealthy nations right so there was just
a study done by I believe it's the
Commonwealth Fund I talked about this
yesterday on the program and as it turns
out there were a dozen or so countries
ranked among five different categories
in terms of their health care systems
and as it turns out the US was at the
bottom of that five categories were
evaluated access to care equality of
access regardless of income
administrative efficiency how well the
care process works and how good the
health outcomes
and the UK ended up first followed by
Australia followed by the Netherlands so
I think we need to look at the systems
that work right why are we tweaking a
system that is morally bankrupt and
economically not viable why are we
focused on tweaking that when we need a
total upheaval now what you're pointing
to Frank is the problem which is if you
apply market logic to an area that does
not have a sort of normal demand curve
you're going to have a bad time and this
is why it's immoral to apply market
logic to health care it's immoral to
apply market logic to education I would
argue with health care you have a very
unusual demand curve if you believe in a
traditional neoclassical economics and
supply and demand curves which are sort
of independently determined and blah
blah blah right that's the standard
stuff you would learn like in an AP
micro class in college in high school
rather or introductory micro and macro
in college you would immediately
understand that the elasticity of demand
for healthcare is not like anything that
would approximate a sort of market
solution you you immediately realize
that it just doesn't make any sense
and if you want to say hey you know what
phones we're gonna sell phones and we're
gonna use the market supply and demand
and we want as close to perfect
pure competition as possible okay I
don't know the logic for doing that with
healthcare and by the way we are doing a
major deep dive as we're calling them we
are doing a major deep dive into
classical liberalism classical
liberalism has become super trendy and a
lot of the people saying that their
classical liberals don't know what the
hell they're talking about classical
liberalism is being used by people who
say I'm on the left but I don't like
social justice warriors and that's not
classical liberalism and in fact this
relates to health care because classical
liberals believe that the market should
be
Abell the market should provide for
anything which is possible for the free
market to provide that means that since
the market can deal with healthcare
inefficiently immorally in a very
depraved manner if you're a classical
liberal you believe that health care
should be in the total free market under
a total free-market umbrella if you're a
progressive but you're for free speech
and against sjw's you're not a classical
liberal I hate to break it to you so
we're gonna do a big deep dive into this
and it is upcoming Darryl Dudley has
sent a $5 follow-up super chat saying
that's it thank you sir my pleasure
Josh 8585 says can't you save money if
you get rid of your name in the number
that people call you for the show by the
way I am NOT a fan I have no idea what
this person is talking about if you get
rid of your name in the number that
people that call you for the show I
think that this person is saying we have
our voicemail number is two one nine two
david p would i be able to save money if
we get rid of that number we're not
paying anything for that I mean it's a
Google Voice number the to david p thing
it's it's google voice we don't pay
anything for it so josh despite not
being a fan i appreciate you looking out
for the bottom line for us but no we are
not that is not an opportunity to save
money
frank macwrite with a twenty dollar
super chat looking forward to the deep
dive your opinion on sebastian Gorka
yeah sebastian Gorka is this adviser to
the Trump administration who has ties to
I don't remember exactly let me see if I
can find my story he's tied to
anti-semitic Holocaust deniers and he is
of Hungarian descent and he is an
absolutely vile vile and totally
depraved individual and it's stunning
absolutely stunning that he is involved
with the Trump administrator
so my opinion of him is quite negative
Frank Giggs has sent a $2.00 super chat
how much of YouTube red views been
helping financially okay so the YouTube
Terms of Service prevent me unless I
want to risk our revenue going to zero
from giving specific numbers but as a
percentage let me pull this up as a
percentage of YouTube revenue this month
for example I'll just go this month
because it's about two-thirds of the way
through the month YouTube red revenue
and for people who don't know YouTube
red is you pay 10 bucks a month and then
you never see ads on YouTube and in
exchange the video producers get like a
fraction of your $10 okay YouTube red
partner revenue is responsible for 8.4
percent of our revenue this month and
Super chats responsible for 6.5 percent
of our revenue this month okay so
hopefully that gives you a bit of an
idea let me do some thank yous I am
asking for your support in getting to
1,800 patreon donors by the end of
today's livestream even a dollar a month
helps okay so seriously if you can only
donate a dollar and I know from the
surveys of our audience that we've done
that 90 percent of our audience could
donate a dollar a month if you're in the
10% that literally could not
I don't want your last dollar okay in
fact I want to keep the show independent
and free because I'm producing it
especially for people who might not have
the financial means to buy shows or get
eh HBO or whatever but if you can't
afford a dollar a month please do it and
Sabrina safar has done that indeed
Sabrina Zafar has pledged two dollars
per month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show please keep those
contributions coming and I will keep
doing the thank yous in addition to that
we have a number of new member
members that I want to say thank you to
if you want a 40% discount off of your
membership after clicking the red signup
button you can then input the coupon
code
I voted 17 into the coupon code field
that will save you 40% and indeed I want
to say thank you to Lenore Hitler who
has signed up using the 40% discount
coupon code I want to send a big thank
you to Mary McQuaid who has signed up
with the coupon code for 40% off I want
to say thanks to Faye lead Dwyer I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly who has
signed up with the major discount as
well as Nina from and clay Johnson okay
thanks to all of you for signing up at
david pakman.com slash membership you
know what I want is to make it so that
this precipitous 85 percent decline in
the YouTube ad revenue means nothing
because what would be better than being
able to say hey you know what it doesn't
matter what happens with YouTube ads it
doesn't matter if the Wall Street
Journal puts out bogus articles saying
look at what's happening on YouTube with
racist videos and advertisements if we
can make up everything we've lost with
the YouTube ad boycott we will be
laughing as we go forward and continue
doing more and more and by the way some
of the things that we want to do I want
to update you I know that there's a lot
of super chats piling up I want to
update you on the long form deep dives
that we are working on there's such good
stuff going on we have a long-form video
which was researched by our intern Brian
who is working with us this summer on
the violent left and when I say the
violent left eye I use air quotes
because there is this apoplectic
movement on the right that says the left
is just so violent and we have done a
really good piece on that totally
debunking it and pointing out that it's
always been the right
has been violent and it still is that is
basically done it's not yet been
scheduled but it's going to be it's
gonna be happening okay we have our our
classical liberalism is pretty effing
conservative that's what we're calling
the video classical liberalism is pretty
effing conservative producer Noah
Ferguson has been working on that the
narration is done we are in the editing
phase for that it's going to be really
good really good that one's about 20 or
22 minutes and I think you're going to
like that we are then going to be
working on debunking socialism has never
worked now I'm not a socialist I'm not a
communist I am NOT a Marxist
I have studied Marx and I think that
there is much of interest in Marx's work
but I am really I would consider myself
more aligned with sort of Scandinavian
democratic socialism and even though the
word socialism is in there democratic
socialism and socialism are two very
very different things however unless we
actually understand history and define
terms there's really no point in even
talking about economic system so we are
going to be debunking the false notion
that socialism has never worked people
often like to say oh look at the USSR
look at Cuba proof that socialism has
never worked wrong we are going to be
debunking that and we also have Noah
Ferguson's working on that one and then
we also have a long-form deep-dive that
our intern Brian is working on on voter
suppression and we are going to
simultaneously debunk the notion that
in-person voter fraud is a problem it's
not and we're gonna go into detail about
it and we are going to show you all
aspects other than gerrymandering
because we already talked about
gerrymandering separately we will deal
with all aspects other than
gerrymandering of how the right is using
voter suppression changing a voting
hours voting locations voter ID all of
these tactics to suppress the Democratic
disproportionately non-white vote in
certain parts of the country okay so
that's coming up and then a little bit
further and and this is why we want to
replace the lost revenue because we have
all these plans right
and I want to just be able to do all
this stuff and not worry about YouTube
ad revenue we are going to be doing a
deep dive on race and IQ okay in the
spotlight recently because of a
controversial Sam Harris podcast with
the author of the bell curve charles
murray but we are going to go way way
beyond that and we've got both our
production team working on it and we've
got some viewers who have particular
knowledge in this field and we're
working on this and it's going to be
really good and lastly and this is
arguably the most ambitious project that
we are that we are taking on we are we
are working on a miniseries on critical
thinking okay mini-series on critical
thinking 12 to 14 parts we are going to
talk about basics of epistemology we're
going to talk about cognitive biases
we're going to talk about logical
fallacies this is a major production so
in order to do this for you to
understand what it is that we're doing
in addition to producing five shows a
week and five bonus shows a week we are
also working on these extensive projects
with which in and of themselves would be
a lot of work and we're doing that in
addition to the five day a week show so
by all means please help out in any way
that you can patreon.com slash david
pakman show trying to get to 1,800
patrons by the end of the stream but let
me get into taking more questions from
you because I see that they're piling up
okay worth one has sent a ten dollar
super check an insurance model is a
total non-starter for health care
insurance is meant to insulate against
disaster we have car insurance to pay
for damage after accidents not to pay
for petrol interesting analogy that is
an interesting analogy and I mean I
generally I agree with your your
conclusion which is an insurance model
is a non-starter for health care I
believe that a for-profit model is not a
is a non-starter for education how we
ultimately solve the problem I'm kind of
flexible on you know I I don't it
doesn't have to go just one way I
I'm open to looking at the problem
different ways whether it's the
expansion of Medicare something like HR
676 which we've talked about whether it
is the establishment of another system
from the ground up and for people who
say we can't afford it we can just look
at the work of Gerald Friedman Gerald
Friedman the UMass economics professor
look at the work of others it's
absolutely affordable Toni Merritt has
sent a ten British pound super chat hey
David I was wondering if you know where
exactly in Eastern Europe your Ashkenazi
ancestry comes from I asked because I
have a lot of ancestry from the South of
Poland it's a mix on my mom's side it's
it is actually let me see if I can
actually pull up a map just so I'm
precise here I had this data easily
accessible and now it's not here okay so
from Poland it's sort of the East of
Poland which borders you will notice
both Belarus and Ukraine and I have
connections to both Belarus and Ukraine
but it's all you know Ashkenazi Jews all
spoke the same language they were
ethnically identical effectively so I
did my DNA test in it and it's basically
that entire region Poland Ukraine Russia
Belarus etc so it's I unfortunately
don't know more specifically than that
Dean Knight has sent a $5 super chat
espionage by the Trump campaign slash
family cover-up by remaining GOP in
Congress GOP threat to national security
death care it's all on American and
anti-patriotic and then denied with an a
supplemental $2 super chat like the like
the GOP the platform need not be
accurate yeah so listen I mean I think
you're getting at something I'm having a
little trouble a hundred percent
understanding the super chat but I think
I get the gist of it you're getting at
something I've been talking about for a
while which is that it would well serve
Democrats
and progressives and liberal minded
independents whoever right I mean I
don't care about party affiliation
you're not going to convince the right
with hammering them with facts right
climate change is a great example the
financials around for-profit health
insurance great example approaches to
the reduction of abortions which they
oppose which are access to contraception
and comprehensive sex ed all this stuff
we're not going to be able to beat them
over the head with facts and change
minds so we really need to do two things
one is focus more on bringing in new
voters on the Left than convincing
trumpets but legislatively we need to be
talking about a lot of these issues in
terms that will appeal to the right
national security patriotism paying
one's fair share there needs to be a
refocus on a refocus seeing I guess I
would call it on a lot of these issues
and I think that thinking about it in
terms of patriotism listen doesn't
really appeal to the people that are on
the Left but we're already on on the
fact-based side so I would think about
that as an approach Frank macwrite has
sent the twenty dollar super chat
sifting through the talk noise of all
the proven collusion it's constantly
repeated there was no crime committed
how valid is that statement without will
anyone be held accountable to different
questions and very different answers how
valid is the statement that no crimes
were committed we don't know we don't
know I think the individuals in the
Trump administration that if crimes were
committed are the most likely people to
have committed crimes are Jared Kushner
Paul Manafort Michael Flynn okay that
would be at the top of my list then next
here would be I don't know I I won't
even go to it next year it doesn't
matter will anyone be held accountable I
don't know I don't know I mean it really
depends on on Republicans because they
control the House and Senate I am going
to talk tomorrow on the program about
we're starting to see the early signs
that Republicans may be starting to turn
on Donald
not all Republicans but some Republicans
and I'm gonna talk about that tomorrow
double X Jamaica has sent a five-dollar
super chat I'm still waiting for Obama
to take the guns away and the FEMA camps
that's why I bought Alex Jones male
vitality pills so I can break out of the
FEMA camps yeah when is that going to
happen never happen and it's stunning
how the gun industry is doing worse now
under Trump because and if this is not a
surprise to thinking people there's
nothing that will sell guns better than
the threat of Obama taking people's guns
and it worked
record gun sales under Obama no guns
were taken I mean just just no guns were
taken now that nobody's really talking
about guns
numerous gun manufacturers are saying
you know are we're not hitting our
estimates we are just not hitting our
estimates our budget estimates for gun
sales because people aren't scared
people aren't scared of anybody taking
their guns it is stunning how well that
works okay major news from the land of
patreon I announced at the beginning of
the livestream that my goal for today is
to get to 1,800 patrons at patreon.com
slash david pakman show the reason for
all this nonsense is that 85 percent of
our YouTube ad revenue has disappeared
completely and utterly disappeared and
that is a really really bad thing it's a
serious thing as our president likes to
say and we need to try to deal with that
and one way that we're trying to deal
with it is by soliciting patreon
contributions we estimated before I do
the thank-yous okay we estimated we put
out about a hundred and sixty videos a
month on YouTube we estimated that
before the YouTube ad boycott if one
person watched all hundred and sixty of
those videos we were earning between
thirty and fifty cents from that
individual so the long and short of it
is and by the way very few people were
watching every video so really we were
earning a lot less from from each one of
our three hundred and eighty thousand
subscribers if you contribute a dollar
you're basically paying for yourself and
two
people right like the lost revenue from
you and two other people is covered so
oftentimes when there are pledge drives
people feel like you know if I can only
do a dollar it's not worth doing
anything cuz like a dollar and zero are
very similar
no no no a dollar covers three people it
covers you and two others and it makes
it so that we are that much less reliant
on YouTube ad revenue okay so let me
start some of the thank-yous because
people have been pledging here Tyler
gigs or I guess it's Tyler aka gigs has
pledged $1 Thank You Tyler
really appreciate it Andrew made an
initial pledge of $1 and immediately
said you know what I can do more than $1
and up to his pledge to $2 Eric Thomas
Ryan sorry
Eric Thomas Ryan Inglot has made a $2.00
a month pledge thank you very much I
really appreciate that and Jo Ann
Mitchell has made a $10 per month pledge
that gets us to 1772 patrons if we can
get to 1800 by the end of this
livestream I will create and release a
half price membership coupon code which
I will only announce to the live stream
viewers ok will only be available to you
won't be promoted on the show won't be
promoted by email or on social media
okay so if we can get 28 more patrons
even a dollar a month doesn't matter
whatever financial level I will create
and release a 50 percent coupon code for
membership and by the way I do want to
thank some new members as well
Keith Moulton thank you so much for
signing up keith has opted to sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership with
the coupon code I voted 17 that saves
him 40% and Darryl Dudley has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
opting not to use the coupon code opting
instead to pay full price and of course
memberships at any level at any level
are very very much appreciated so keep
it going and let's see
if we can hit that 1,800 patron mark and
then I will release a 50% coupon code to
you Klaus and 54 let's jump back into
the super chat Klaus M 54 has sent a 5
euro super chap he says concerning the
critical thinking subject
thanks for addressing the topic please
try to identify narratives that can help
to spread science and reason yes that is
absolutely what we are going to try to
do and we have if you missed it I told
that one of the deep dives that we are
working on is a 12 to 14 part miniseries
about critical thinking where we will
talk about epistemology and critical
thinking logical fallacies we will talk
about cognitive biases it's going to be
tremendous
but that's why we're trying to replace
the lost YouTube revenue but Jacob Jung
has sent a five dollar super check Trump
is almost surpassed Obama's eight-year
total civilian kill count in the Middle
East what are your thoughts yet you know
Jacob I opted not to cover that story
because the headline is really up it's a
stunning headline which is in his six
months fighting Isis Donald Trump has
already killed as many civilians as
Obama killed fighting Isis over eight
years the tactics and approaches have
changed drastically from Obama to trump
because the nature of Isis and its
location has changed so I felt like the
headline was not what it was made out to
be and I did not feel as strong about
the details being a coherent narrative
so I opted to sort of put that story on
my keep track of it and check in next
week and see if I can flesh it out in a
way that makes more sense but yeah I did
see that story Tina Howard has sent a
twenty dollar super check David are you
familiar with the indivisible movement
it's basically the Tea Party for the
left I think they've been very effective
in conveying their concerns with their
Republican state representatives do you
you know Tina I don't know much about
the indivisible movement
let me see if I can there's a movement
I'm just gonna make a note to check it
out afterwards I know that they put out
that guide to resisting Trump and I
looked at that and that was pretty
interesting but I'm not beyond that I
haven't looked into it too much their
website looks pretty pretty solid and
I'll check it out after the livestream
so thanks for the suggestion okay
game fire 74 cent a $14 and 31 cent
super chat I think Trump asar becoming
more unhinged I've been seeing comments
to start literal civil war upon Trump
impeachment used to think it was
hyperbolic is it conspiratorial madness
or real threat you know I don't want I
don't believe that real threat or
conspiratorial madness are the two
options I believe that the Bundy ranch
fiasco and the fiasco that Bundy's kid
was involved in if you remember that
emond Bundy I don't even remember that
guy's name I think that that proves that
Republicans and right-wingers and
whatever you want to call them these
patriot militia types they are willing
to take out their guns and start trying
to make things happen to at least some
degree I do believe that the impeachment
of Donald Trump would absolutely set off
some significant portion of these
individuals no doubt about it
that being said is it going to be civil
war I don't know I I don't know I would
not write anything off I would not even
dream of saying no there's no chance in
hell that these people if Donald Trump
were to be impeached go absolutely nuts
but I not say that that is that is a
guarantee I would hope that there would
be some sense talked into these people
if that's what they were thinking of
doing but I don't know
Eric Inglot sent a $5 super chat to my
extreme Trump is grandparents Fox News
is becoming center-left what's your
opinion on some let's say Santa
slipping into FoxNews yeah I did a story
yesterday and I don't know if you saw it
but you could check it out Eric it was
about sort of reality surfacing briefly
on Fox News and it was a segment where
Chris Wallace and Shep Smith basically
said hey this isn't normal a ton of lies
are being told and we're not we're just
not being told the truth about what's
going on here why and this this is this
is not nothing and I mean Fox News is
not center-left
Fox News is in a very tough place now
where they are trying to figure out well
how do we manage this how do we deal
with what is increasingly a disaffected
group of more traditional Republicans
and yet the expectation from the
hardline alt-right trumpets that we
support and defend Trump at every step
and I don't know what the answer is Fox
News is not center-left that I can
assure you but at the same time it's bad
how can anyone ignore what's going on
right I mean it's it's it's it was bound
to bubble up at some point and I don't
know I I mean Fox News is not
center-left but I don't know what the
future of Fox News is in the Trump era
Trump used to love Fox News now they're
actually being slightly critical of
Trump I am having a major problem with
my internet connection and storms appear
to be rolling in so before risking
getting cut off I'm going to cut this
stream at this point thanks to everybody
who has pledged at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I do want to send a
last thank you to ace of logic John
Condry and a huge thank you to Louise
Henry who is putting a pledged a big
league $25 per month thank you so much
please keep it coming we will have an
update on the pledge-drive at the end of
the week and I am out also going to try
to do another live stream before the end
of the week if not to because I can tell
that there is there's a lot of questions
that people have and I want to get to
all of them so thanks for joining me we
will
this again very soon subscribe to the
YouTube channel if you haven't we're
almost at 400,000 subscribers